[Musique]
côté supporteurs ce prologue du paris
nice c'est la bonne occasion de revoir
les idoles de demander un autographe
michel par exemple suit la carrière du
directeur sportif de l'équipe de la
française des jeux
marc madiot depuis 27 ans en suivant
tous les coureurs de la française des
jeux indien cantonnés sur une course
on encourage toute l'équipe six à neuf
coureurs on applaudit les neuf coureurs
donc on équipe et drapeaux supporters
vêtements supporters voilà on a la
panoplie du parfait supporter et même de
petits nuls l'ourson la voiture quand on
est passionné de cyclisme c'est assez
formidable d'être au contact les voir
passer dans à côté de nous et tous enfin
c'est dans ces tops je sais pas comment
dire mais bon c'est ça ça ça fait
quelque chose
côté coureurs l'ambiance est plus
concentré après une reconnaissance du
parcours le dimanche matin à la
mi-journée l'heure était aux
échauffements pour les premiers partants
du prologue ça c'est compliqué il ya une
bosse de départ avec un petit secteur
pavé bon
les positions général quand même se joue
aussi un petit peu au début sur certains
paris nice il ya pas vraiment de les
gros leaders les dix premiers il n'y a
pas forcément de deckard ans quand il ya
des arrivées au sommet donc c'est
important tout le monde
cette étape hier encore du chemin à
faire donc bon c'est un maximum
aujourd'hui mais
on verra aussi les prochains jours il ya
des choses à faire c'est le néerlandais
lars boom de l'équipe rabobank qui a
remporté ce contre-la-montre de 8 km
autour de montfort l'amaury en dix
minutes 56 secondes
[Musique]